Chicago gay bars are boycotting
transheiser bush
yes you think white why are the gay bars
boy cutting transheiser Bush I thought
it was the conservatives boycotting
transheiser Bush we are also boycotting
transheiser Bush everybody is boycotting
transheiser Bush why because
Bud Light and the team over there have
taken their most clear step to distance
themselves from Dylan Mulvaney they said
it was one can we didn't sell it we
didn't sign off on it we don't like it
please leave us alone
but they didn't quite go far enough
to earn back the support of the
conservatives who actually bought their
beer
they've just gone far enough
to irritate the leftists and the
pro-lgbt people who have been buying Bud
Light in protest of the conservatives
not buying Bud Light in protest of
transgenderism so Bud Light yet again
has made the worst decision available
to it
what are they saying
several gay bars in Chicago are
boycotting actually all a b inbev
products that's Anheuser-Busch was
bought by this Belgian company inbev
and they're doing it because of
anti-transgender actions and statements
two bears Tavern group
Bears isn't that a gay term right that
like big big guys that like big hairy
guys it owns four gay bars in Chicago
maybe it's just a Chicago thing like the
Chicago Bears I don't know I don't know
I don't really want to know say all two
bears Tavern group bars are
discontinuing
Anheuser-Busch inbev products as a
result of the Brewers anti-transgender
actions and statements their response
quote shows how little Anheuser-Busch
cares about the lgbtqia plus community
and in particular transgender people who
have been under unrelenting attack in
this country
Bud Light doesn't listen to me they
don't want my advice I guess I don't
know they keep making the worst decision
possible there is only one course of
action that can help you Bud Light your
first course of action that could have
helped you was shutting up they couldn't
do that so okay your second course of
action the only one that can help you
right now is you need to come out firmly
and strongly against transgenderism
against the whole Preposterous ideology
you will never win over the LGBT LMNOP
people there aren't enough of them to to
sustain your beer company first of all
second of all there the ideology is
completely out of step with reality and
so you're going to alienate the broader
public that does not have have this
particular pathology
but three
if you stand in the middle of the road
you are going to get hit by a truck
there is no way to avoid this particular
issue certain political issues you can
avoid them as I made clear in my CPAC
speech which set the whole liberal
establishment spinning this is one of
those issues where you can either women
have bathrooms or they don't this is one
of those fundamental issues
and the the
loving compassionate truthful
smart business decision kind of response
that you can give here is we oppose
transgenderism that was wrong we fired
the people who sponsored Dylan Mulvaney
we support Frat Boys and construction
workers and boys and girls having their
own bathrooms we are strongly against
men competing against women in sports
we're strongly on the side of reality
Bud wiser this bugs for this bud's for
you we're going to recast the frogs
we're getting we're firing Mulvaney
we're gonna put the frogs back in the
commercials and you know what we're not
even going to turn the freaking frogs
gay we're going to go back to normal
please buy our beer again we are sorry
Maya culpa Maya culpa Maya Maxima culpa
if budalite came out and said that
people would buy their beer again
conservatives who don't even like their
beer would probably buy it just to just
to show support for this statement and
to show the rest of corporate America
that they need to get on the on the page
too
they would do it anything short of that
is not going to work it's just going to
irritate everybody and then Bud light's
going to go away right now go to
genucel.com Knowles if you're still
looking for the perfect Mother's Day
gift that will make the women in your
life feel pampered and appreciated our
friends over Virginia cell have you
covered geniuselle's most popular
package is specially curated to nourish
and rejuvenate your skin right now
they're offering seventy seven zero
percent off this package which includes
their Ultra retinol and Dark Spot
Corrector this nighttime moisturizer
contains a powerful retinol alternative
to visibly reduce the appearance of Fine
Lines wrinkles and skin discoloration
without the irritation of retinol my
producer Ben Davies should use genucel's
ultra retinol because he comes in he
looks Haggard I say Ben I don't want to
commit an HR violation but you need to
look better you got to check out genucel
of their products I love the under eye
bag treatment I think it's just great
they have a guarantee if you don't start
seeing results right away they will
offer you your money back I also also
love the founder of geniusell great
Coptic Christian from Egypt left Egypt
to go pursue the American dream try
geniusell's most popular package during
their Mother's Day sale for seventy
seven zero percent off at genucel.com
Knowles every most popular package
features their Ultra retinol and Dark
Spot Corrector get a complimentary Spa
Essentials box with every package order
from now until Mother's Day they'll even
upgrade you to free priority shipping
don't wait genucel.com Knowles
geniusell.com Knowles right now go to
cozyearth.com use promo code Knowles
moms deserve the best of everything
including the best night's sleep this
Mother's Day give your mama super soft
luxurious designer preferred betting
from cozy Earth cozy Earth's luxury
bedding and loungewear transforms lives
by offering the world's softest most
luxurious and responsibly sourced
betting with an eyesward quality
responsible production Cutting Edge
technology and premium materials cozy
Earth selects only the best suppliers
they have over 5 000 happy customer
reviews on their site they offer a 100
night guarantee on their sheets and
their sheets get softer and softer with
every wash
invest today in a good night's sleep
when you sleep well your life goes well
and the mama in my life uh the mama to
my two little boys uh is absolutely
thrilled about Cozy Earth I'm sure yours
will be as well cozy Earth has a huge
Mother's Day sale going on right now
save up to 35 off with my promo code
Knowles Canada wlas cozyearth.com promo
code knows a check out for 35 off your
order at cozyearth.com speaking of
not gay bars but speaking of places with
silly costumes that have a reputation
for being a little bit light in the
loafers
Mary old England just
suggestion over the weekend maybe you
watched it maybe you saw the the plumes
and the robes and the carriages and
everything
I don't have much to say about the
coronation obviously the United States
broke away from England some time ago at
the UK broke away from the my church
sometime before that and
it's not my thing I get it but I did
watch the coronation
and
I I did enjoy large parts of the
coronation
there were many many faults defined with
it there are many many faults defined
with King George
there are many many faults defined with
what has happened with the royal family
and with the UK in general but
in a world that is so
fanatically opposed to tradition
How could a conservative not celebrate
the coronation of the king of England
you don't need to be a monarchist you
don't need to be a Brit you don't need
to be an Anglican you don't need to like
Charles you don't need to do any of
those things in a world that tells you
past bad present crisis future always
better in a world that tells you that if
you don't chop off your kids genitals
you're a bad parent we're going to take
your kids from you in a world that tells
you that Christianity is a joke and God
doesn't exist and we're just a bunch of
meat sacks that need to eat the bugs and
live in pods and own nothing and be
happy
in a world that tells you that then even
the coronation of a pretty liberal guy
who Pals around with Klaus Schwab who
has kooky religious views who has all
his problems in that world it seems to
me a conservative has to celebrate the
maintenance of some kind of tradition on
a chair that's what 700 years old or
something like that in Westminster Abbey
which has hosted every crowning of the
king going back to the Norman Conquest
in
it just it gives you something to hold
on to
and that's I think what we're grappling
with in our political order we have
nothing left to hold on to part of this
is the building okay part of this is the
the fact that this is a big beautiful
abium we don't build things like this
anymore we don't even build big
courtrooms courthouses and train
stations anymore used to be early 20th
century New York if you walked into a
courthouse
you were in a big Grand Place you felt
like you had dignity when you came into
New York City you showed up either in
Grand Central or the old Penn Station
and it was big and Grand and you felt
like a person with dignity and then
everything has become smaller and
courthouses now look like little meeting
rooms from some paper company and train
stations look like little rat mazes that
what they did to New York at the old the
old Penn Station they put it all
underground you enter New York feeling
like a mouse or a rat and that that
changes how you view yourself
and you view your Society the reason we
want big courthouses the reason we want
big palaces the reason we want big
Cathedrals and Abbeys for that matter is
for the feeling of solidity the feeling
of continuity over generations to build
those Cathedrals it would take
generations and many many decades over a
century sometimes
and that that feeling of inertia and
weight and history and near permanence
has been lost and if we can hold on to
that to get through a little bit of this
cultural Madness
then I'll I'll look past a lot of the
faults even if somebody like King
Charles
I won't even go down the truth the the
line of thinking that gets us to the
true king of England who's obviously the
Jacobite successor the Archduke Franz of
Bavaria or his brother Maximilian or uh
his grandson Prince Joseph Wenzel of
Liechtenstein I'm not even gonna go down
that path I just think we ought to
celebrate
the very fact of a celebration of
tradition like the coronation man that
was some clip make sure that you get all
the clips and the whole show and the
long interviews and the yes or no game
and everything by subscribing here to
the Michael Knowles YouTube channel ring
the bell ding the dong hit the thing
we'll see you next time
[Music]
foreign